Zach do you remember the casting process
for a Christmas story oh yeah the
casting process in a Christmas story was
a cattle call I was 12 years old
I went there with my mom there were 300
kids and you walked in front of a camera
giant VHS camera put these huge tapes in
and I was the sidekick I wasn't the lead
bully so the lines were now your aunt
Fanny get over here like that was kind
of it so you do that over and over and
it went from like 300 down to 200 150
180 50 10 and then apparently I got the
job and then so I learned how to say now
your aunt Fanny many times and then I
got the job and we're shooting in I
think it was Cleveland Chloe I think
Cleveland was the first place we shot
and we get out there and we're dressed
up in our wardrobe so I get the great
hat and the 1940 stuff which is itchy as
hell and then I meet Jana and ayah who
plays Grover dill and the wardrobe
mistress takes us out to Bob Clark I've
never met him before because everything
I did was on tape and so he's sitting
there in a low chair it's freezing and
he's got a big puffy jacket on and the
wardrobe mistress walks up and says hey
Bob so this is your Grover dill and
here's your skip Farkas and I guess that
was the first time that Bob saw the
height disparity and he looks up he's
like oh oh
right you get his lines he get yours
great good action and that was it so
that's how I became house kept Farkas
became the bully and Grover Dale became
the sidekick and did you learn the other
lines before yours
were you were you one of those or you
just only saw your lines it was pretty
easy I mean it wasn't rocket science
there were no soliloquies in the
Christmas story and my mother's an
actress so she would just run it with me
right with me over and over again and
then when we actually were shooting Bob
would come up and had he treated us like
young professionals so if you were
fooling around being a kid that's great
and now we're shooting and you drop your
line
he'd walk over and I remember there's
one scene I dropped my lines three or
four times and I think I was distracted
and I was being a silly little kid like
and Bob walks her ovaries are : cut hold
on everybody and he walks over to me and
he puts his arm around me he's very
fatherly he's a gonna attack
I run the line and I ran is like good
okay running again I did is it good one
more time one more time
wait what was it like okay do one more
time and again ooh you know what when
we're done honey and one more time start
squawking mangoes wait wait Zack what
was that line perfect thank you let's go
because he expected you to be a
professional but he was also a father
she was very kind and that sort of set a
standard for have fun but bring your A
game and show respect to the set and you
can have fun and dick around when you
know your lies
according to your IMDB it says that the
role for Scutt Farkus came down between
you and another red-haired boy at that
time yeah and let's just say that the
other actor got the role and you didn't
okay okay do you think things would have
taken off because you know how they say
the one thing usually kind of sets
people in motion and they would always
see maybe scut all the time do you think
that that changed everything that one
instance of you I know you've had
several callbacks I guess for the role
mm-hmm change things for you in terms of
if you didn't get it but you still came
to LA maybe you came in your 20s
identically to try to take your shot
that you would be here grinding it out
the way psyche talented people are as
well I think if I didn't get a Christmas
story then definitely my life story
would be different because when
Christmas story came out it wasn't a
success nobody liked it it was in the
theaters for two weeks
and then it was replaced by Rambo - I
think it then came out a following year
nobody cared Leonard Maltin retracted a
review that he had posted apparently he
had liked it the first year but then
said this is a great movie but really no
one cared it wasn't really until the
twentieth anniversary where its tipping
point became sort of galvanized
Americana to be something that they all
said yes this is our Christmas movie and
I think it was at that point forward
where people just appreciated that I've
been in it it was wasn't that cool you
know that guy was skip Farkas yeah no no
chef that guy yeah still acting yeah
he's still I think and it was it be kind
became kind of a fanboy thing honestly I
hate I did a TV show for Joss Whedon
dollhouse and I need an epitaph on an
epitaph - and his brother Jett Whedon
and is Marisa his wife cast it
and jet was saying later he he was just
so excited to work with Scott Marcus and
I think what was odd about it is that
you know all the other kids Peter
Billingsley as a producer does Ironman
it works with Vince Vaughn so he's got a
huge production company and when a
different way from an earlier age and I
did and so he doesn't really have the
same experience he doesn't really care
to talk about it it's not something that
he puts a smile on his face I've had
sort of the opposite experience which
was I've been working after all my life
and so for people to come up and go oh
my gosh we want you every year and it's
great and my little kid Billy I got him
Red Ryder BB gun he's like yeah it's
like yes oh yeah nice to meet you son
and then the grandfather was like you
like that when I was your boy you know
in all this it for me is the best
Christmas experience there is and I
think I would miss that most of all I
think how it affected my career is it
made people realize my longevity and
know that I'm sort of a marathoner and
not a sprinter Zac do you feel an actor
has control over their career in
Hollywood
I don't does an actor have control over
their career okay that's a really hard
question to answer you have options that
you can try and execute but unless
you're producing directing and
distributing you really don't you you
have to do the best you can and let the
chips lay where they lay because it's so
much that you can't control and he had
Academy award-winning actor Sir Ben
Kingsley playing in the film and I
learned a big lesson from that film
which is that a crappy director can make
Sir Ben Kingsley look like a crappy
actor so when Sir Ben Kingsley Academy
Award winner looks like a half ass in a
feature film you know it's not sort of a
Kingsley's job that he didn't do it's
the rest of the process so you try to
generate as much content as you can you
can control the scripts you involve
yourself with if you have the money to
pay the rent otherwise you can try and
tweak out the scripts you work on with
changing the dialogue or make and
bringing your a-game when it comes to
acting and helping out with a
choreography and really being on set
knowing you're blocking but once you
walk off that set they can do whatever
they want to with your material and you
have no control over that
unless you want to shoot everything
yourself which nowadays is an option but
when I was a kid man up until what 10
years ago eight years ago that wasn't an
option
so maybe nowadays yes back in my day no
god I sound so old this is great
do you believe anybody can make it in
Hollywood mmm
I do not believe anyone can make it in
Hollywood I do not believe anyone can
make it anywhere you have to have a
certain level of talent and you have to
have a level of work ethic 90% of
success is just showing up and you have
to go do it and there's there's a lot of
people who wish they were actors and
they're really really horrible at it
they suck like I can't make it as a
singer I can't sing to be a singer no
but I would love to be the person who
when he sings in the shower someone's
like that's really that's really good
I'd like to be able to sing a romantic
song and my girlfriend I don't want to
hurt the poor woman so I choose not to
but it's it's a skill set and and make
it in Hollywood in what in being a DP in
being a set designer and and being a
visual effects designer and matte
painter practical effects because it you
know anybody can take the materials the
silicone and punch the hair but it comes
down to your subjective view of elegance
and design whether or not you share that
with everybody and so I think Hollywood
is the same as any mechanism where
you're creating an art form it has to be
at a level that other people want to
share because if it's crap they don't
want it I'm referring to in front of the
camera and when you say that it takes
talent and work ethic which do you see a
lot of people putting
or the talent and taking a lot of
classes hmm it's hard because so many
people want to be actors cuz they're
pretty I would say that wasn't my
motivation it depends upon what their
goals are when they get into it if they
think that because they're pretty and
everybody at the high school wanted them
to be king of the prom and they can see
themselves walking that red carpet and
have everybody high five them then like
I you know those people always exist but
like there's millions of them and there
aside from being pretty unfortunately a
lot of times they're very bland and they
don't carry a story value that connects
with people makes them care they don't
have a sense of vulnerability and and
pain and that they share with people to
identify with I see a lot of them and I
don't care for them to be honest I I'm
not jealous but you want to bring up
like Brad Pitt look at that gentleman's
career and he's gone from being
incredibly sexy to incredibly sexy and
incredibly deep and really pushing
himself as he becomes older and and get
adding gravitas to his roles and mocking
himself and becoming kind of meta about
who he is and being self commentary I
think that's a real accomplishment for
someone who is the a-list or pretty boy
value but so that's the work I think you
put into it
choosing how to see himself differently
now I don't know if you can do that if
you're 21 years old and really really
really really really super good-looking
it's interesting when you say that's my
blue steel by the way
Jew Lander okay when you see bland is
that because they haven't gone through
sort of some of these arcs that the ones
that maybe didn't get asked to the dance
or didn't get chosen for whatever social
group experience I don't want to make
gross generalizations because that's not
fair and but if you're incredibly
good-looking things in your life are
easier and we know this since we're
children really pretty people have
people doted upon them like if you're
you're a pretty woman and I'm sure when
you were a little kid you were a pretty
little girl with big eyes and people
like oh-ho what are you to do no one
says that little squirts landing I had
redheads you look at me like oh you have
a baby so it's a very different dynamic
and I think that people who don't have
what's the word I'm looking for
they don't have issues they have to
overcome on a regular basis then they
don't find their own internal strength
the same way they don't have that thing
to relate to when it's too easy for you
what do you draw up on what's the most
insane risk you've ever taken in your
career
moving to Los Angeles was the most
insane risk I ever took in my career I
left Toronto I had a TV series called
boogies diner and his garbage
it was the shows were like Saved by the
Bell but nobody saw it so that's awesome
it was a Canadian show in a Jimmy
Morrison on it now at James Marsden you
may know him as Cyclops from the x-men
the back then he was just Jimmy and it
was crap like you should really look it
up how bad it was
it was it was horrendous no it was funny
because it was Canadian
it had to be shown on the Canadian
content channels so you have see FTO or
City TV in Toronto these are Canadian
channels and they they would have to
show a certain amount of Canadian
programming in order to qualify for
whatever they have to qualify for so
they put they put us there was cheers
great show and Seinfeld and in between
them was our piece of crap boogies diner
and if you look at sitting up you'd be
like that's bad it was horrible and I
would be out in a bar something that
people like turned me go hey I saw your
show it's like oh really to go yeah it's
great you're working it's really good
you're working like no it's I know
exactly what it is but when that
finished I felt like I had hit a level
in Toronto that I was going to
constantly be that waiter walking into a
big movie saying you know salsa or these
tiny roles and just didn't matter and I
wanted to take a shot so I left Toronto
moved to kid Los Angeles stay with my
father lives up in Pasadena and I I
lived I went from having a beautiful
apartment down on the lakeshore in
Toronto to
sleeping my little brother's room on a
pullout bed underneath his bed and I
would wake up with gerbils and puppies
peddling on me which is awesome and
first couple of jobs that I had I think
the first one was for the AF AF M no AFI
American Film Institute and it was his
I think it's called corner of gold if
you look it up myself long hair back
then and like yo and I shot this thing I
had almost no lines and you gotta
remember I had a series that was
my second series in Toronto I had done
this for years I made a living doing it
I made a lot of money doing it not crazy
money but I mean like a hundred grand a
year back that's like 25 that's a lot of
money dude had a nice car a nice place I
come out here I'm meat eating ramen I'm
starting over again and I do this thing
and I'll never forget this this guy
turns me after we finished shooting this
whole thing cuz that come here I want
talk to you like yo yo I didn't have the
glasses back then so the eyes are much
bigger and the hair is long and just the
goober and I'm like yo what's going on
he's like you know Zak he was the sound
guys like you know Zak gum just want to
say I was watching you you're really
good
really hey you're really good you're
really talented I think you're gonna go
somewhere yeah I have something for you
he reaches in his car D to English in
the wallet takes out a card and in my
mind I'm thinking maybe my shot I knew
would work no one worked out for me she
just got a believe and he passes me at
cards like you called them you tell them
I gave him you tell them I giving the
card in my name like thank you so much
shake his in I don't even look at it yet
I just want to say thank you thank you
so much he turns around he walks away
and I'm like and it's an extras casting
company and I had never done extra work
in my life because I grew up doing it
and it kicked me the balls so hard that
I realized that I had to start again
where no one gave a and I rode my
motorcycle home it was that motorcycles
from 1978 I had to wear a garbage bag
over my body taped around my arms
because I couldn't afford a rain suit
and I wrote back to Pasadena and I
thumbtacked that on the door and every
morning I got up I looked at it I just
was like you I'm gonna do better
every single day so it that was probably
the craziest thing I've ever done what
year was this 95 this is when you came
to Pasadena yeah kid man okay came to
Hollywood came to Hollywood but state of
Pasadena
yeah and did you ever call the did you
ever do X you know so you use that as
like this fuel yeah yeah and then once
that whole conversation took place how
soon before you booked something whether
it was just a bit partner cause I booked
a movie about three weeks after that for
what's the guy who did all them he did a
little shop of horrors Roger Corman a
Roger Corman was doing a thing for
Showtime back when Showtime made crap
and this was the Roger Corman horror
hour thingy movie selections so we did
this into this movie called star hunter
which is Stella Stevens Roddy McDowall
and myself and Rebecca buttock and
ken Scott and it is it is horrible it's
horrible but it was awesome
I was shooting I was doing movie stuff
and I was up and running that's good and
you rode your motorcycle from Pasadena
like 4:00 a.m. to be on set yeah I do
you remember how you felt that first day
ecstatic ecstatic because that's
something that I was comfortable with
like I always I was comfortable I'm
comfortable being on set doing my job
helping people do their job being part
of the crew getting it done I've been a
PA an office PA a boom man and a grip
back in Toronto so I new set decorum
backwards and forwards and I grew up on
my mother's need be a backstage and
theaters or on film sets so once I hit
the set I'm ready to rock and roll
but trying to overcome the machinery of
all these people I don't know in
Hollywood the casting directors and how
to get there wasn't very very
intimidating when did you throw that
business card away still have it did you
take it down at some point from the door
yeah yeah but yes in a file well I still
got it what's the file called I don't
know it's just in one of my filing
cabinets and it's you know you open up
and ghosts come out when you're making
decisions about your career how often do
you listen to other people and how often
do you listen to your gut
I make my decisions based upon good
advice from people who are smarter than
me and then my own innate feeling as to
what I trust about the situation and
that's that's changed over the years as
I've been giving that a lot of study
recently excuse me
there's a there's a book called never be
lied to again they based a TV series
called lie to me on it and it's about
micro-expressions and I can honestly say
that the biggest mistakes I've made in
the last eight years that have had the
longest reaching ramifications
financially and timewise or because I
didn't trust my gut and your gut is
really your brain processing
micro-expressions and telling you that
something's wrong and you're not
listening to it so I I use that and I
trust that a lot more and then going for
walks is I think very important getting
away from my phone my computer other
people's opinions going for a walk is
listening to yourself and talking it out
I am that guy here walks in circles
talking to himself because it's helpful
so I try to use a combination of that
but when it comes to being on set when
I'm directing something
career decisions come down to what the
shots going to be the lighting working
with my talent I will defer always to
the people who have a lot of experience
in the technical aspect and are so good
at that technical aspect that they have
kung-fu and now I've brought it up to an
artistic level because I've worked with
them for years and when they give a
suggestion there's a lot of weight
behind it so that's how I offset my own
opinion with others yes yeah that's the
garbage truck okay we have them here in
Hollywood
so the canines smile you know the taint
when they show that that's actually a
sign of aggression is it but so and then
that was what I learned from
micro-expressions too because I okay
recently found out about it or how our
right brain shows on our left side of
our face or what yeah right or using a
base systems that figure out where
somebody's song the truth or where
they're uncomfortable and they're
remembering a lie they look to one right
yeah yeah so you set up a base yeah
right or if they're trying to lie they
say things like yes you're right I will
completely do that you like what why
does it feel uncomfortable where do you
walk around my backyard around the
around the block over the 7-eleven go
back yeah it's not glamorous it's just
like how did the script for don't blink
find you or did you find it I would say
I found it I worked at raising money for
financing for a bunch of years and I
really knew I had no idea what I was
doing and eventually I was introduced
through my producing partner Carl Carl
Lucas introduced me to gentleman Nathan
Laurie Eskie last name very difficult to
say and they agreed to give me money and
they said Zack you can write it direct
to produce it star in it I said
no I don't wanna new the head because it
was the first thing I was doing as as a
producer and I didn't know how to do
everything at one time I said them look
I'd like to produce or direct and on
this one I want to produce and I have
somebody I think would be a good
director for it and then also my scripts
at this budget level are more comedy and
I don't think they travel as well
because people laugh in different
countries and the cultural value of
comedy doesn't really transition well in
other languages so comedy is do okay in
the country but not necessarily outside
but everybody goes boo the same way and
then starring in it like I would like to
get bigger names in me in order to help
guarantee distribution and so those were
my thoughts then a friend of mine Travis
Oates it was I was working at Acme
comedy theater I was part of the Acme 18
so every Saturday night you do basically
like sir tonight live type of thing
sketch comedy and he was the owner of
Acme at the time and he was script
writer who had sold a bunch of different
scripts to large studios and so we had a
stable of really good scripts and he had
this concept for one and so I told him
the budget level and he wrote the script
in like three days yeah he's that guy
he's like guess it doesn't super fast
and so he did it and he directed it so
yeah I brought him on board and then I
brought Brian Austin Green on board and
Brian was the contact to mena Suvari
because they worked together on the
movie Domino and Brian and I had worked
together on Terminator the Sarah Connor
Chronicles and which is a funny story
because I play a hero from the future
and so if you're coming from the future
to the present and the terminator world
you're naked so that's a great way to
meet the entire cast and crew
dude I'm a white guy I'm a ginger so
this is you know needs a tan you know
I'm saying and so the first thing is
like I give my macho pose future ball of
cosmic energy
and my chest explodes because I've been
shot in the future and then it has a pow
urgh and I go away and I'm walking
around thereby like hi this is a nice to
meet you
kind of embarrassing a goddess and I'm
sitting down and Brian off some greeting
walks over and he's a big dude like I
don't know if you know that but like
he's like six two ish and he's like he
looks like he's plays football he's a
big cat and I'm singing no set in my
bathroom feeling uncomfortable and he's
eyeballing me he's like I don't know you
okay I don't I don't know you saw me
naked over they heard it might be ways
like no like this tightest that things
like no I thought it was could be this
no dates no name there's an evil
apocalypse almost Facebook no no I don't
think Christmas joy is like oh my god I
love Christmas story my son knows
Christmas story watch it every year and
he pulls a fan boy it was hilarious I'm
like okay creepy I'm not wearing any
clothes so we start butting it up and
then I reached out to Brian and I told
him about the script he read it he loved
it
he came on board which was huge and
Brian is very talented
I think watching him and I you know I
didn't always work really before since
9:00 which one oh I hadn't really pay
attention to him and I didn't really
care for 9:02 I know because I was in a
little girl teenager girl so when I saw
him on Terminator I was blown away by
how good he was like holy crap he's just
really profoundly depth full
and so we came on board with us I was
very happy and then he brought a Mina
and that's how we got everything kind of
running I think I answered a question
you did it what was the timeframe from
when Travis write he wrote the script
days then when did you actually go to
the location and start shooting
Bhagu Bhagu we got the script we've got
the money in my gagas of mm yeah we got
it like August and then we got
everything set up written locked down
location scouting casting October and
then started shooting January January
second more a second Wow so yeah it's
still still with champagne residue hair
hair yeah it was awesome and I went we
were shooting in Ruidoso New Mexico but
Karl is from Roswell New Mexico and
there's a film class film you know the
film Department right sorry
tired film Department in there and
there's also like military barracks
nearby so I'm staying like military
barracks on a cot you know and my my
girlfriend at the time was like whoa
what are you just looking for Christmas
and like sweetie I I've got a movie
Santa Claus came this is all good I
don't need anything else all I want to
do I want to go through contracts I want
to learn the DGA
this is all of them that's all I wanted
there was nothing else that anybody
could give me besides that that was just
ecstatic so yeah we shot for 22 days
yeah six to eight weeks which as always
everybody who's a filmmaker out there
will know six-day weeks suck and the
first day back after the one Day weekend
nobody's friendly
we talked about earlier that a lot of
people don't want to do things
themselves so how much of this putting
together don't blink was about you
keeping stuff going forward in your
career you don't strike me as a person
that waits yeah I've had the I've been
blessed with the opportunity to work on
a lot of films I've I think my IMDB is
107 and I've worked with Cameron Crowe
which is amazing and I've worked with
mr. Spielberg fantastic and I worked
with Michael Bay incredible technical
director and really knows his stuff and
I've worked with people who don't know
jack dick and it pisses me the off
so I got pissed about that and I had a
choice
shut up or put up and I can't shut up I
guess up too big a mouth so I decided to
keep pushing for it and trying to make
something and that yeah don't blink was
about turning talk into action and
seeing if you can do it get in the ring
throw some punches worst case scenario I
fail but at least then I'd know and if I
didn't try then I finished this life
doubting myself and knowing that I'm a
liar because I never put my money where
my mouth was so I had to I really had to
there was no option of yours 107 I
thought I saw actually hundred knee but
107 ish credits how many of them were
that same mentality I
how many of them were letting people
choose you first Oh I mean when it comes
to hmm I mean that's up on the feature
films it depends upon the project if
they're you know lower budget projects I
obviously have a lot more control over
when I'm working on transformers I'm
really not in charge you know I'm
working almost famous hmm
I did get to pitch stuff to Cameron
Crowe which was cool I got to change up
some lines in there and tweak it out and
which is good but you know the really
don't blink is the first film that I
produced I associate produced on a film
called monster month and I've directed
one short film but those are the
extensions of me trying to grasp things
and make them happen and always a
difficulty is doing the job is not hard
for me getting the money to do the job
is the hard part and then making sure
that you once you get the money and do
the job you get the money back to the
people who gave you the money so that
you can show them the respect for their
investment and then you can move on to
the next one and that's not an immediate
process so it takes a while would you
say you're detail-oriented yes how do
you follow up because what I've seen
with a lot of people is they have such
great intentions and they don't follow
up on stuff it seems like to you you you
follow up you maybe tie up loose ends I
would consider myself detail-oriented
because when I was a kid I used to come
out to LA to visit my father my father's
general contractor and one thing I was
really good at was painting and messing
that up but cleaning and even today if
I'm on set i broom as I go so that
there's nothing left behind there's
nothing to trip over and I was gonna get
hurt I also worked in kitchens as a kid
so there's a yes chef
response my my PA is on my cruise and
like ladies and gentleman like yes sir I
need this does everybody have it yes sir
thank you guys there's a respect level
but I I do that so that everybody
understands what is required and if they
don't go no I don't understand that okay
clarify that because I don't want
anybody running around in big circles
and coming back with empty hands cuz it
wastes time which wastes money we don't
have a lot of money
I'm detail-oriented because it's easier
to do it right the first time than to
apologize for it up and I know
I'm gonna screw things up but not out of
a lack of due diligence so I try to be
as detail-oriented as I can be not to
micromanage but in order to ensure the
fluidity of the work process
I get the sense that don't blink was
your biggest risk yes don't blink was a
huge risk in the sense that it was my
first movie that I produced so I was
convincing people that I should do it
and that they should give me their money
and trust me with their money and go
finish a movie and give them a finished
product and I would not drop the ball
and I mean I didn't go to film school I
didn't have anybody give me a booklet I
couldn't like oh wait what's the answer
their problem oh it's right there is it
that often thanks guys we do the thing
so it's over there I had no idea
and you know it's always funny when you
look back on your life and you realize I
was stupid you were and I'm full of crap
you were would you like we can do it and
so yeah it was a huge risk for the
investors and a huge risk for me because
I was not willing to stop there I mean
there were so many times when there were
issues and frustrations and problems
that you wanted to be like Oh oh my god
I can't do this anymore this is insane
because on a film budget like that I I
paid myself like 10 grand to produce and
stuff acting the thing and it took many
years to get this done so
I know people who wash dishes who make
more money good people good friends but
yeah they're they're making Bank
compared to me I get made fun of by
Busboys is what I'm saying so there's a
point we like I can't do this like you
just exhausted but I realize I couldn't
that was the thing is I couldn't not do
it because then you never get another
shot no one will ever be like hey I
heard you up your first movie I'd
love to give you more cash no so the
only chance I get is to make this movie
as best I can get it distribution dance
like a monkey at bar mitzvahs until
enough people buy it and my investors in
the black then we high-five and make
another film but yeah it was I guess if
I really knew what I was getting into
back then I might have back pedaled but
that's kind of the joy of being stupid
wait I think they just insulted my song
do you even get stupid or do you think
it's maybe having that intuition that I
gotta do this like - you know that was
Mark Mayer and I watched him on
something and he said yes he's like I'm
47 he's like this is like my life this
is now yeah do you think that you have a
realization that this is now and I need
to make this house yeah I have that more
now I'm 45 and I feel there's a there's
a great poem by a dutch anonymous poet
and it says live as in quotation live
death whispers in my ear i am coming
and I don't mean that melodramatically
but banned all marches into the same you
know fairground so I feel like I'm
enjoying it more now I don't feel like
I'm desperate to try and prove something
I am proving it just by my life and by
my actions but I am very grateful that I
threw my hat over the fence - have you
ever the John F Kennedy story
I haven't John F Kennedy when he was a
kid they used to
he went to high-end fancy schmancy
schools and they wore uniforms and they
would have a hat a cap on and when
they're coming home from school they
would walk by these gorgeous estates and
they'd be thinking what the wonder
what's in there over the fence we should
go check that out over there you know
like well we can't we'll get in trouble
and JFK would take his head toward
Rovers like well now I have to go so I
throw my hat if that makes sense
did you have any sleepless nights oh
yeah do you yeah but two years yeah this
is don't blink is my baby yeah and I
walked around patting the foam canister
like this and burping it and changing
you so the hard drive yeah when you got
stressed out was your way again till go
for a walk turn off the phone go and
then think it out and get some kind of
clarity or there was that when in
moments of conflict
it was very important to drink a lot of
scotch no it was important to yes become
breathe deeply watch other movies watch
other movies and if possible watch the
directors commentary and the producer
more importantly for me that producers
commentary because it helps you want to
put things in perspective even great
movies have problems you watch a movie
just want to visit true romance great
movie love that film there's some
editing fuck-ups in there hard to find
him not gonna bring him up but there's
some definitely will that doesn't match
it's not a match cut edit his arm was up
here in one shot and I was down here in
this other side you like but that's okay
so it gives you that ability to stop
taking every nanosecond so personally
and you have to you have to make
Buddhist produce aerial decisions that
are for the betterment of the film and
for the investor as well as for the
audience and can't be masturbatory and
then there's issue because you can't
just be like it has to be this way or
nothing you have to make a product that
people want to watch and the investor
can get their money back
as opposed to never having it end and
being overly overwhelmed with this one
microcosm right here where you have this
whole universe to deal with and trying
to get a perspective on it yeah it
really is a life-changing experience I'm
sure I need everybody I'm sure that your
audience watches and builds movies
themselves and I'm sure they know
exactly what I'm talking about and you
stayed in a different area during the
filming right we're in New Mexico
explain your process for that when we
were shooting don't blink in rio dos in
new mexico we had we were talking
off-camera but we at the top of this
mountain
it was a developer i was making a sort
of like a gated community where there
all these house opportunities and we had
three different houses up there the big
beautiful cabin that you see the movie
shot in and then this other incredible
house another incredible house do it
they were like to weigh in for the cabin
1.7 1.8 and like freakin fantastic and I
put the ladies up in this one and the
dudes up in this one and we do direct
your level bud as I said use that the
garage of this one for catering and
because you got a crew of like 80 people
and then you got building props over
here and then over here you get
production and makeup and all that so
every square foot was utilized luxurious
but like utilize and I stayed down the
mountain with my producing partners Carl
Lucas and and Alan Trevor and also the
post-production supervisor and we would
swap out who took the couch and the
reason I want to do that is you know my
cast I put in these beautiful houses and
really the accoutrements are incredible
you've got pool tables and giant screens
and jacuzzis on on decks overlooking
forests and massive valleys it was
stunning and I didn't stay there for a
couple of reasons I wanted my cast to
have a great time I wanted them to be
excited and feel important and that they
were doing something more than the
budget of the film I've done a little
bunch of feature films before as an
actress solely and when I showed up on
one project and we are you know
Winnebago five banger five bangers when
you've got like a little room little
room little room little room little room
right and you've got place for a bed you
walk in the door there's a bed and
here's the sink over here is a toilet
you get the out like that's it
right and I remember coming to work on
the star of this little low-budget film
la twister and the whole thing is
flooded with poop water from the toilet
and I still have to get dressed in there
I'm still
Apple box going over the bed get
my done going like really dude like
really come on look really because
you're not giving any money so you're
supposed to be in it for the art but
it's trying too hard to focus that when
you smell like your own poop that's not
the world that wanted to create so by
putting my actors up in those areas they
felt glamorous they felt we are actors
and they needed that and then by keeping
them away from me and my producing
partner we could go into the the are
building and we could lose our
minds or discuss things and who's a
problem and who's not and how we could
tell the issue without them taking it
personally because you don't want to do
that around them because they're not
seeing the overview they're seeing I'm
acting and you might be like you know
it's great but this person spending 15
minutes too long in the chair makeup
chair every day well in 20 days you know
I can't give him that much time that's
costing me money this cussed me over a
thousand bucks no we had to trim this
down let's move it along who's gonna
bring her breakfast in the chair get her
coffee because if we start with her hair
she can meet in the burrito while that
when she does that then went that'll
save this time but you don't wanna do
that in front of an actor you want to be
there going hey man good morning how are
you you look great all the stuff looks
so good yesterday so good Oh God so
they're excited right and also as a
producer I kind of wanted to keep a
separation from the cast so there was a
little bit of difference so I was like
hey guys we got to tighten up get a move
they're like oh okay yeah that guy's
still kind of a dick even though we're
acting with them all right fine we got a
topic a little bit we started talking
about people seeing dailies
no no problem is anybody out
there is watching this walk by a mirror
what do you do you make your mirror face
mind horrible I got slanting eyes to
start off with so when I do my mirror
face they basically disappeared the
freckles on my face but everybody makes
a mirror face because you're making
comparison about how you see yourself in
your mind to what you really look like
I'm always sadly disappointed but the
reality of the matter is when an actor
is looking at the monitor they're making
a mirror face and they start going oh I
don't know if I look good in that angle
well off and the angle is not for
you to decide this for me to decide as a
director producer if I'm producing this
from my director to choose if I'm
directing this for me to choose because
you don't know where it goes in the Edit
your job is to be doing what you do
fantastically caught up in that emotion
if you're trying to tell someone I love
you so much
and you're looking for your angle you
suck and you're ruining my movie I need
you to be that raw person that is right
for the moment and if they start looking
at the monitor then they start posing
when they do stuff and now now you're
now you're useless now you might as well
go Hitchcock and shoot their hands from
actually a minute rest of the scene
because you can't use their face and
their eyes are line so yeah I do not
allow my cast look at the monitor they
can look when they've wrapped on the
show if they drop by they can watch
somebody else's it takes not their own
we had a student in middle school
message us recently and they said you
know enjoy your videos would like to get
into acting but they explained what was
holding them back and they this is what
how it reads well many reasons but for
the most part it's problems in school I
stressed out a lot of about school
because of bullying I'm still
kind of shy I'm working on getting rid
of this bad habit I guess the shyness do
you have any advice for me I've stuck it
in my mind after this school year I will
start acting hmm okay I've got some
advice for you
what's this fellows name well we're in
their own anonymous oh okay anonymous I
have some advice for you act if you have
a camera and you have a computer then
you should find your favorite movies of
all time and find your favorite scenes
of all time from the your favorite
actors of all time and do those scenes
just do those you don't have to show me
anybody else but yourself just do that
you can do that all by yourself
without anybody judging you and you can
play you sitting from the camera
practice every script I swear to god you
can find any script you want online
print it out then you can read the
script you can go over the scene on the
TV you can watch how they're doing it
you can sort of compare and then you can
play with it and you can make it your
own
don't try to imitate that person try to
make it who you are because you're
obviously if you're gonna do Scarface
you're you're not him
you're not Al Pacino you're not a late
30s mid thirties year old guy from maybe
you're a kid maybe you create your own
backstory for that where did he come
from how did he get that scar that'd be
cool right then you shoot it on your own
camera and you watch it and you can
think oh my god I suck that was horrible
and you can laugh about it guess what I
watch stuff that I did before and I'm
like that moment was horrible but I can
do better those moments where you suck
are just as important as the moments
where you're good because they help you
make a comparison value of your own
sense of
objective art so do that play enjoy the
process and then when you watch other
people you go to an acting class outside
of your school so it's not involved in
any of that social crap that goes on in
a high school which honestly anybody
who's getting bullied out there you got
to realize if you're in high school this
is just going to end real soon dude and
real life takes over and nobody cares
about those people the bullies and
actually in the real world everyone
thinks their dicks so when someone goes
from being a bully in high school and
comes out of high school and it's still
like yo dude what's up how's it going no
one likes them they don't get good jobs
and they fail in life miserably so feel
better by yourself go find another
environment where you don't have that
bullcrap social aspect about your acting
class and have fun doing that and
remember watching other people is as
important as being onstage yourself I
still do it if I go to an acting class
I'll watch somebody else and even if
they suck and sometimes nothing wouldn't
they really suck I wonder why they suck
I don't have to break it down in my head
like why do I think this person is just
not hitting a comedy or the dramatic
beats like Oh cuz they're doing this do
I do that I did know one time you know
hmm okay okay good point good point
thank you very much I'm again talking to
myself
but that's as helpful for me as when I
do something really well and because if
you're involved in the process your goal
isn't to be the world's greatest actor
in two seconds your goal is to enjoy the
moment-to-moment experience of emoting
and feeling the reality of that story so
when people watch you they feel the
reality so you can start doing that all
by your lonesome with
camera of any crappy camera that you
have you can have they have like iMovie
although it's the worst editing software
there is it's on your freaking phone or
yeah hot-wired cars sell it and buy
editing gear I'm kidding you don't do
that but that will help
there you go anonymous go get em tiger
was there a defining moment when a
casting director regular director just
said oh you're a character actor how did
you know that let's see when I was
younger I got the opportunity
opportunity to audition for some really
good roles and I was told I didn't get
them because I have red hair and
literally I remember one specifically
where a great part TV series Canadian TV
series where the character I'm going for
is beaten up very badly and this other
guy's buddy is killed and my character
is potentially on trial for being the
killer and this horrible secret is the
other guys is gay lover and they love
each other dearly but he doesn't want to
say that because he's afraid his father
will disown them so obviously this is
back in the 80s and early 90s back when
being gay was an issue so I get to have
this great on a couple of auditions and
there's so much pain and fear in the kid
my character and I've got like a roomful
of 12 people weeping and
it wasn't a great cathartic experience
for me and then I was told that they're
like oh you're great but it's just the
red hair looks like what the does
that have to do with anything you can
diet or you know there are people who
have her hair we're not from Mars yet
dick like yeah now and I realized that I
was never going to fit anybody's
expectation I was no one ever wrote in a
script like this really super
good-looking guy with slanty green eyes
and freckles and red hair and kind of a
dick but kind of a lovable dick walks in
the room like they don't do that there
was that and then I remember audition
for this horrible horrible piece of crap
TV series called silk stockings and the
casting director I think she was a
character from The Simpsons because this
is back of the day she was smoking she
was smoking and the road like this she
drove like this the entire time
hey I can't remember name she was skinny
as a rail I'm sure she had 12 cancers at
the time she's just walking like this
the whole time and I come in I do the
part she's looking at my red headshot
resume shake you're good active not
really what you call a look but Jim
you're a good actor it was like what do
you mean I look but I want to be a
looker my mom so it was just it was just
the experience of constantly being cast
as the good-looking guys best friend or
the good the person who eats the
good-looking guys dog or the kill a bad
guy
it's just they assume that you know
casting is very linear in its thought
process and you know I went from doing a
bunch of movies and then
dramas and their like today I went to
audition for Titus
sitcom they're like oh that can't do
sitcoms he does a dramatic film and then
I do Titus for three years and then I go
to doing a dramatic film like who's that
can't do climatic film he just tied us
and literally it went back and forth
over and over again so I call myself a
character actor because I because I
become what is needed to get the job as
opposed the job looking for me because I
fit what they want
does that make sense so when you hear
someone say something like that and put
whatever meaning you want to it what the
casting director for so exciting isn't
it do you almost view yourself as a
third person because you realize you
know what she's not really referring to
me even if she is right but you almost
see yourself as like another entity at
that point so then you can keep doing
this yeah you gotta you look at yourself
when you think what's the product I'm
selling right and you know if you're
Josh Duhamel Josh is a great looking guy
Josh and I work together on transformers
he's a sweetheart
he's awesome he's not getting jobs as
the serial killer he's getting jobs as
the guy who finds a serial killer and
beats him up or the fireman who defeats
the bad guys or that you know that he's
because when people look at him he's a
very handsome six with four guy so
they're like we want a leading man Boop
he hits that now I'm not saying it's
better for him because of that because
there's a lot of guys who look like that
who don't have any work I think in some
ways it's easier for me to keep on
finding roles to fit into and like I
said it is what are you selling when I
when I look like this I've got glasses
and a t-shirt and short hair and I look
very
I'm serious and professional I put on a
wig long hair like it did in blood rain
- I look sexy as I'm covered in
tattoos I've had / I did a movie where I
was covered in tattoos so the longest
hair to do this around here I'll down
here tan it was a spray-on tan shut up
and I'm with a guitar which it
cannot play guitar ok can I play the
guitar and the producer walks by I was
like you should be a musician
did you look just like a musician like
might help if I can play an instrument
dumbass
or sing but it's all about the
perception of what you're selling now
but I didn't want to wear fake tattoos
for the next 20 years and continuously
try and sell that one thing to me it's
something I put on so I guess that's why
I'm a character actor because I blend
into the character in order to fit the
role whereas other roles go after they
fit themselves around the performer did
that make sense it does what's your
advice to actors who come out here and
want to be that leading person because
that's a bitter pill to swallow yeah
they're good-looking
yes you are and for whatever reason if
those casting directors didn't see you
as the leading man how do you make that
switch inside you that says well I still
want to act well I mean it's it's again
back to the camera thing it's such a
different world that you can constantly
be creating your own reality now you
don't need a 35-millimeter camera you
don't need a Hannah
vision freaking camera you don't need a
1.3 million dollar rig you can have a a
five hundred dollar rig and you can do
it yourself and try and you can put
stuff on YouTube and like the actors now
that are really interesting are the ones
who do push themselves and I think that
paradigm has shifted massively it's not
just I'm Johnny Depp and everything and
now he's shifting it up again but it's
the Breaking Bad's the games of Game of
Thrones
the the shows that are pushing the
limits of the characters envelope are
the ones that are now being touted as
the level of excellence whereas before
it wasn't before it was oh they're
pretty right
are they pretty we all wanted to be
pretty and now you look at Sons of
Anarchy freaking awesome show but it's
about the character not just about the
symmetry of the facial lines I think
anybody who's starting up now should
look at that as an opportunity even if
you're freaking gorgeous play with that
because you can always go back to being
beautiful but try try the ugliness look
at again Brad Pitt but also Bruce Willis
in twelve Monkeys they both went
wackadoo Charlize Theron oh my god a
monster
freaking awesome got her an Oscar and
she's crazy hot why do you think some
talented and lovable child actors having
have trouble making that leap crossing
over and sometimes turning on themselves
I think child actors have difficulty
transitioning to being an adult for a
number of reasons one depending upon how
famous they were when they were kids and
how they were treated and how indulge
they were is very dangerous it's
dangerous too if you're just a parent to
treat your children with kid gloves let
alone imagine all the the luxuries a
celebrity child gets and then becomes
accustomed to it and then you know you
saw me and Christmas story not I
handsome kid and I'm getting this big
like I hit this stage when I was a
little kid I had little nose I had big
eyes I had like these cheeks chubby
cheeks
I hit a certain age like I got the thing
came out I had the braces you know
everybody's got this period in their
life where their hormones are just
trying to make them as a sexually and
unattractive as possible so to go
through that and to continue working is
is really difficult and then I guess it
also depends there's construction
outside so it might speak up it also
depends what it is you want to
accomplish because if your goals when
you were a kid was to be doubted no not
doubted fawned over is where I'm looking
for it to be fond over and pet in the
head and praise well then as soon as
you're off set and on the red carpet
then no one cares and if your show wins
then the pewag know you know whatever
happened to you if your job is to if
what you find satisfaction in is the
process of it then you're gonna keep on
pushing forward and when I was a kid I
shoveled walks I grew up very very poor
so when I was like six years old I was
shoveling snow off of neighbors walks
for anywhere from thirty to fifty cents
per pop I was delivering newspapers I
was working as a stock boy I worked in
kitchens I worked at a guy named Toby
was a shimada's dealer
I worked for my dad painting and
cleaning and brooming and then I got
into martial arts when I was ten ten to
eleven a couple of to three years there
I was doing fencing they got in the
Taekwondo and I get into boxing and then
I had a bunch of amateur fights and then
I traveled but the thing is I like being
in the gym I like being in the dojo I
like doing the bag work I like doing the
ground work I like getting stronger I
like doing the job I like eating but I
like cooking the meal I like being in
the kitchen using the knives cutting the
stuff up and making it look cool and
putting new flavors together
I like the process I don't just want
people go yeah you here's food I want to
actually make it so I took that attitude
towards working and it wasn't about the
red carpet for me because in Canada I
never got a red carpet I think
that was a saving grace and I I think
again I'll reiterate it make your own
stuff I have a friend of mine James
comer ESIC this little bastard is 22
years old and as directed 12 movies dick
if you're watching it James you're a
dick and he is first one
I mean he's 18 years old getting it out
there and he used social media to launch
it as high as he could and he's calling
all the film festival like I'm a 19 year
old filmmaker take pity on me and he
made a pretty crappy movie but guess
what they all wrote him up and he got an
Amazon I was on like in the top 30 of
all movies all and his movie not so
bueno but the fact is he got it he's
doing it he's doing it he's doing it
he's doing it and because
did it cuz he didn't stop it didn't wait
for someone else to give it to him and I
think with younger actors when they're
trying to transition if they sorry I
mean it that when they become back in my
day especially I think what you're
referencing is the different strokes
kids and the Cory Feldman's and the
Corey Haims and the people who ended up
being kind of disasters and doing
cocaine and getting heavily into the
drugs and and making bad decisions and I
know exactly why they did that and I
didn't have that success when I was a
kid I I would say the closest I got to
that was really when I was doing Titus
and I had a 500-person audience and in
the last season the Titus I was like a
Beatle like I had kids lined up
boys and girls cuz the character was
kind of androgynous ly sexual towards
both genders which is awesome and you're
like we logo and I'm like I'm married
but thank you very much and I do
remember like the high of that live
performance being so great and wanting
that not to stop I started to drink too
much because at that point I wasn't
writing
I wasn't pursuing financing I wasn't
going on lynda.com learning how to edit
I wasn't going to the National
Association broadcaster show in Vegas
and talking to everybody and asking
about how software works and asking
questions I wasn't buying tools I was
buying toys and hoping things were gonna
work out for me no one taught me I had
to figure it the out and I wanted
that high to continue and so I click
lick lick lick ike leggett a good luck
and that wasn't I'm not a you don't get
smarter getting drunker you don't get
anything else accomplished you talk
about it - we should showed you that
thing or a tiger woman can you're
awesome for that and then you wake up
you're like what happened oh that's
gross did we shoot that movie no we just
talked about it crap so I understand why
they did that in the eighties those kids
and because they couldn't grab
or they felt they couldn't grab a camera
but now cameras in and editing gear and
a portal for distribution being YouTube
or whatever you want to try it's
ubiquitous
it's everywhere it's affordable you can
borrow it
you know if your buddy has a camera and
you don't paint his house borrow his
hard work will get you everything
you need pretty much and then talent and
more hard work gets it in the next way
and I so I hope nowadays that people can
feel the freedom to transition and still
feel creative like I'm a don't blink
I'm an actor for 35 years now I'd like
to be acting the rest of my life but
more importantly I'd like to be creating
for the rest of my life and if I'm not
in front of the camera because my name
infront of the camera is not bringing
money to the to the production then okay
let somebody else have that position
because that's respect for my investors
but I also get to be creative my life
doesn't end because I'm not on the red
carpet or I'm not the one being
interviewed
I'd just be as happy asking the
questions